[Musique]
j'admets que le teaser pour confirmer la
saison 4 my pet pour faire cette vidéo
pourtant bien que le but de ce teaser
soit très simple soit confirmé la venue
d'une quatrième saison
il souhaite en cash et plus qu'on ne
pourrait le penser que veut dire ce nous
ne sommes plus à hawkins
nous pouvons très clairement penser que
la prochaine saison se passerait du côté
d'eleven vivant chez les bailleurs ce
dans leur nouvelle maison
ce serait la raison la plus logique il
se pourrait que la saison se passe
durant des vacances scolaires comme
celle d'été dans la troisième saison est
donc que mike dustin et lucas soit venu
quelques jours pour voir will et f
néanmoins ce nous ne sommes plus à
hawkins peut également signifier que la
menace est maintenant situé à kamtchatka
en russie est donc qu elle est éloignée
de hawkins désormais mais quelque chose
me fait penser que nous serons tout de
même à hopkins
enfin oui et non sur ceux disant nous
voyons très clairement le panneau ou
welcome to hawkins
alors pourquoi dire que nous ne serons
plus à hawkins et bien car nous serions
à hawkins
mais dans l'aube saïda je pense que ce
n'est une surprise pour personne
il est obligé que plus nous avancions
dans la série plus nous allons avoir des
informations
de fait et de temps passé par rapport et
dans l'aube saïda cela fait maintenant
trois saisons que le mind flyers agit de
moins en moins dans l'ombre et vient
dans la réalité des humains pour faire
un sacré bazar cie lé réalisateur
souhaite réellement avancer dans la
série il faut la faire évoluer et
changer le but
hopper a de très grandes chances d'être
dans hawkins mais dans l'aube saïda et
il faudra qu'il soit secouru les démons
d'orgon qui à la base était des monstres
redoutables deviennent aujourd'hui des
outils d'exécution pour les russes bref
il va falloir creuser cette question de
l'ops haidar ne monte encore d'un cran
la dangerosité et aller à la source si
le but final de la série et de vaincre
le mind flyers il faut aller à la source
du problème à l'origine du flash et leur
mental l'obs aida les frères de feurs
avait déclaré qu'il comparait et s'était
inspirée pour le mâle fire de voldemort
de la saga harry potter et donc qu'il
n'était pas 15
simplement str mes pensées et
réfléchissent et ils nous l'ont prouvé
avec la saison 3 si nous raisonnons
comme dans harry potter voldemort et
dean mortelle entre guillemets et se
maintient en vie grâce à cette horcruxes
qu'il a créé et a donc divisé son âme en
sept parties
ces objets c'est horcruxes sont à
l'origine de la survie de voldemort
je ne sais pas si vous voyez mon
raisonnement mais le même qu'ailleurs
provient de l'obs down
il en est originaire il est obligé que
la source est son origine se trouve là
bas
cela fait maintenant trois saisons qu'on
nous montre et nous prouve qu'il est
impossible de fermer la porte au monde à
l'envers
depuis qu'il a été ouvert et comme dans
la saison 2 tué le cerveau permettrait
de tuer les sbires tuer le masne flyers
dans l'obs aida où on supprimerait la
totalité des démos corons
bon il est vrai que nous avons commencé
avec du très lourd mais retournant un
peu sur la base du trailer ce dernier
bien que très court est vraiment bien
conçu comme avec par exemple les quatre
temps à la fin pour signifie que nous
sommes à la saison 4 néanmoins si vous
avez pu l'entendre un son d'horloge est
présent et il ya un sens là dedans
effectivement on commence à avoir
l'habitude dans le cinéma un tic tac se
répétant constamment signifie un stress
une pression du temps qu'il faut se
dépêcher un combat contre la montre un
combat contre la montre face aux mânes
flyers très certainement si hopper est
en vie et cela prendrait tout son sens
car il faudrait aller le sauver et nous
ne savons pas ce qu'implique réellement
le psy down mais il est possible qu'il
ne faille pas y rester trop longtemps ou
bien que le my fire a ressenti la
présence d'eau peur et est actuellement
à sa recherche
et justement les quatre gong à la fin un
retentissant souligne la finalité de ce
contre-la-montre comme si l'acte à
éviter ou à atteindre était arrivé à son
terme il est possible qu'avec ce détail
la saison tournerait autour du chiffre 4
bref le trailer reste en tout cas très
classique dans sa conception et rappelle
évidemment les trois premières saisons
tout va bien et tout à coup le lien avec
le side and ressurgit lit et le masne
flyers la menace n'est donc toujours pas
terminée enfin voila je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait grand chose à dire de plus
l'horloge présente souligne très
clairement qu'un rapport au temps est
présent et nous pouvons accessoirement
voir une maison en arrière-plan avec la
lumière qui s'éteint certainement un
lieu important de cette prochaine saison
mais surtout qui souligne ici la fin de
la vie et le début de l'obstacle da
j'espère que cette petite vidéo vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
réagir dans les commentaires à me
laisser un pouce bleus et vous abonner
sur ce je vous souhaite que le meilleur
c'était tango rock et que le 'lion'
force soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]